en janvier 2018 le ministre de
l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanquer a souhaité installer ce conseil
des sages à ses côtés composé d'une
quinzaine d'experts d'horizons
différents et chargé de préciser la
position de l'institution scolaire en
matière de laïcité de fête et de fait
religieux
depuis lors ce comité ne se contente pas
de de réfléchir et aux rapports parfois
difficiles qu'entretiennent le religieux
et la politique et le politique au sein
de la communauté éducative
il veille aussi à éclairer de manière
pragmatique les acteurs de l'éducation
nationale en matière de laïcité vous
avez ainsi créé en collaboration avec
les services de l'éducation nationale 1
bat d'aimer comme destinée à apporter
des réponses concrètes aux personnels
éducatifs directement confronté au fait
religieux dans l'exercice de leurs
fonctions vous vous rendez aussi sur le
terrain pour former études de cas à
l'appui les personnels de l'éducation
nationale aux questions de la laïcité au
regard de la diversité de ses actions et
vos connaissances de votre connaissance
de ce qui se passe sur le terrain nous
aurions donc reconnaissants madame la
présidente de bien vouloir nous dresser
un rapide bilan de l'activité de ce
conseil au cours des trois années
écoulées
nous souhaiterions également que vous
nous préciser le regard que vous portez
sur l'évolution du nombre et la nature
des atteintes au principe de laïcité
constaté dans les établissements
scolaires au cours de la même période
et puis bien sûr à l'issue de votre
propos préliminaires jeu je suis certain
que nos rapporteur stéphane pieds noirs
jacqueline eustache brinio et dominique
derrien et l'ensemble des sénateurs ici
présents ont des questions à vous poser
pour entrer peut-être plus dans le
détail de certains aspects nous cédons
donc la parole madame pour une un propos
liminaire dix minutes
dix minutes et on va dire 15 minois la
des minutes un quart d'heure quand smith
merci messieurs les présidents
on m'a transmis un certain nombre de
questions auxquelles on souhaitait que
je puisse apporter quelques quelques
réponses présidente du conseil des sages
de la laïcité c'est au ministère de
l'éducation nationale soit que ce soit
bien précis alors ces cinq questions
il ya une question générale et quatre
questions particulières sur le conseil
le conseil des sages sont as
rapide sont très factuelle je voudrais
vous parler de la première question qui
était une question générale sur le
projet de loi qui était le projet de loi
vous paraît-il marqué une évolution dans
la conception française de la laïcité
pensez vous qu'il risque de porter
atteinte à la liberté du culte
alors là je vous parlerai peut-être plus
tôt en tant que sociologue qui depuis
des décennies
travailler sur ces problèmes plutôt
qu'en tant que présidente du conseil des
sages mais bien entendu je répondrai à
toutes vos questions alors sur ces deux
questions
ma réponse est clairement non
dans les deux cas je ne pense pas que
c'est une évolution dans la conception
française la laïcité et je ne pense pas
qu'il risque de porter atteinte à la
liberté du culte et je voudrais vous
donner quelques éléments qui m'amène à
cette affirmation
la loi de 1905 comme vous savez a été
conçu en fonction de l'église catholique
en tant que puissance politique et
c'était dans une période où toute la
france étaient catholiques c'est parce
que sont les croyances par définition
mais dont la vie collective était
organisée pas une église unique qui les
historiens nous ont bien montré à quel
point la france n'est pas contrôlée mais
enfin et ai été vraiment organisé par
l'église catholique et c'est ce pouvoir
qui était en question et comme c'est
être en contre ce pouvoir politique non
pas contre l'église bien que certains
étaient contre l'église mais en face la
loi elle-même a été portée par la
volonté de remettre en question le
pouvoir politique de l'église catholique
et non religieuse elle a eu évidemment
le grand a depuis des religions
minoritaires de l'époque qui à elles
deux c'est à dire les protestants et les
juifs devaient faire 3 4% de la
population le grand rabbin que vous avez
déjà entendu à vous a expliqué tout
l'adhésion passionnés des juifs aux
règles de la laïcité donc je n'y reviens
pas ils l'ont
num contrairement aux protestants qui
ont été très très passionnément laïque
au moment de la loi de 1905 et qui
maintenant sont critiques sans jeu ne
comprennent absolument qu'elle il
fondement de leur critique mais peu
importe donc là la situation actuelle
est différente dans la mesure que la
société est fondamentalement différente
elle est beaucoup plus diverse elle est
diverse par le degré de pratique de la
plupart des grandes religions
traditionnelles par un éclatement des
croyances et des organisations
religieuses dans tous les domaines
je vous envoie des travaux les
sociologues de la religion elle est
moins religieuse dans l'ensemble donc
pour la population majoritaire en même
temps elle comprend des mouvements de
retour éventuellement extrémistes c'est
à dire que on est religieux de manière
tout à fait différente dans la mesure où
on est religieux aujourd'hui on les
manières différentes de celle que
connaissait la société dans laquelle a
été élaboré celle de 1905 et il ya là
l'existence d'une forte proportion de la
population qui est difficile à évaluer
mais enfin qui est de l'ordre de 10%
deux populations musulmanes et donc les
conditions sociales et politiques sont
très différentes allant chaudraies
qu'ils soient très très claires que le
problème est l'islam politique c'est pas
l'islam en tant que tel
encore que certains islamologue sont
plus nuancés dans leurs rapports entre
islam et islamisme
mais je pense très
avec beaucoup de conviction que un islam
religieux de type religieux impose à la
loi de 1905
des adaptations s'agissant des lieux de
culte bien sûr puisque la france était
couverte d'église en 1905 malgré les
destructions de la révolution et qu' il
y avait la grande mosquée
essentiellement en 1920 dont il y avait
il ya un problème d'adaptation de la loi
à des conditions différentes pour les
lieux de culte pour les fêtes
éventuellement pour le régime
alimentaire et je suis convaincu que ces
problèmes peuvent être réglés par une
adaptation de la loi de 1905
on invoque toujours le l'exemple des
usines renault qui avait fait venir
prenant un terme nous des populations
musulmanes des pays musulmans et qui
avait adapté qui avait ouvert des salles
de prières qui avaient pris des
dispositions au moment du ramadan bref
qui s'étaient adaptés à des demandes qui
à ce moment là étaient des demandes
purement religieuse et je crois que
l'exemple de renault est très frappant
quand je les demande était d'ordre
purement religieux elle pouvait trouver
une réponse de style libéral et
d'adaptation aux conditions des gens ce
que par parenthèse la république a
toujours fait pour reprendre les clans
des juifs que je connais mieux dans les
années 30 dans la rue des rosiers
l'inspecteur d'académie avait tout à
fait accepté que le jour de repos soit
pas le jeudi comme c'était dans toute la
france mais le samedi parce que il y
avait il y avait le shabbat donc ce type
d'adaptation à des religions
particulière
la revendication proprement religieuse
de l'islam ne la remet pas ne la remet
pas en question elle demande
effectivement de s'adapter comme on
s'est adapté à la moselle et alsace en
fonction de son histoire comme on sada
comme la loi de 1905 et le principe de
laïcité s'adapte dans les régions
ultramarines qui sont dans des dans des
conditions différentes
le problème c'est que maintenant il ne
s'agit pas de revendications religieuses
mais que au nom d'une religion
il y as derrière une un véritable projet
politique contestataire des valeurs
démocratiques
alors il ya eu un grand à un grand
moment dans cette évolution qui est
autour de l'an 2000 mais je vous
rappelle
parce que sans doute vous savez qu'en
2002 il ya eu déjà le livre sur les
territoires perdus de la république
qu'en 2004 jean pierre robin qui
maintenant est connu mais à l'époque je
me souviens encore d'avoir parlé avec
lui jean pierre robin était un cas
intéressant parce que c'était un homme
de gauche classique je dirais la
république et la laïcité comme allant de
soi comme ne faisant pas problème est
qu'il a découvert avec ahurissement
qu'il y avait des collèges ou un
responsable à un directeur
d'établissement lui disais je les
derniers enfants juifs est parti parce
que je ne peux plus assurer sa sécurité
alors ce rapport a été très
soigneusement mis de côté nous avons été
quelques-uns il ya une publication de
l'année suivante nous avons été vains
d'intellectuels qui commentait le
rapport obin et qui disait qu'il fallait
en tenir compte
qui n'a eu vous l'avez remarqué aucun
écho personne n'a jamais parlé de ce
texte mais je le cite non pas pour dire
que nous avions vu
voir les choses mais simplement pour
montrer qu'il y avait déjà à ce moment
là les éléments qui permettait de
comprendre qu'il y avait un changement
dans ce qu'ils apparaissent de ce qui se
présentait comme des revendications
d'ordre dans l'autre religieux qu'elle
était déjà des revendications politiques
avec de l'antisémitisme et maintenant
donc nous connaissons tous les travaux
qui montrent le mouvement de l'islamisme
depuis gilles kepel son étude son ancien
élève michon les travaux de rougier
enfin maintenant où nous disposons de
ces prêts est donc le problème est
devenu tout à fait politique
il est et les différentes dispositions
qui sont prises dans cette loi dans leur
inspiration me paraissent répondre à un
problème qui encore une fois est un
problème politique et je me suis réjoui
que le président de la république n'est
pas remis en question la loi de 1905
parce qu'effectivement ça n'était pas un
problème religieux mais c'était un
problème alors je vais vous dites faire
quelques réflexions sur le projet de loi
avant de passer au rôle du conseil des
sages de la laïcité
j'ai apprécié le changement de nom de la
loi parce qu'il me semble que il faut
rappeler que la laïcité est un régime de
liberté et qu'en donnant un sens
positif un titre positif on a eu raison
deuxième point il me semble et je crois
que le grand bain vous l'a dit aussi que
le passage de la loi de faire passer
certaines associations cultuelles de la
loi de 1901 plus libérale enfin pas
libéral m'enfin qui ne demandent pas les
mêmes contraintes à la loi de 1905 et
naturel
s'agissant d'un projet religieux
je trouve normal non seulement que onze
subordonne la des subventions publiques
à des associations à la signature d'une
charte de la laïcité mais je dirais même
que même s'il n'y a pas de subventions
publiques qui me paraît normal de
demander à des associations de respecter
les lois communes qui font partie de
notre vie de notre vie à tous et il me
semble que l'idée de se scandaliser de
la signature de cette charte est quand
même surprenante
j'ajoute que les vous avez remarqué que
les trois associations musulmanes qui
ont refusé de signer son tout turc et
que c'est donc la politique du président
horaires dogan qui s'est exprimée ce qui
va dans ce sens je vous dis que c'est un
problème politique et pas un problème
pas un problème religieux et donc rendre
des comptes et préciser d'où vient
l'argent des les pays extérieurs ne
paraît pas en tant que tel scandaleux
alors je un des problèmes qui a été
beaucoup débattu c'est le problème de
l'enseignement familiale on peut
regretter qu'on ce qu'on passe d'une
d'une situation de sans autorisation
préalable de contrôle a posteriori on
peut le regretter et personnellement je
le regrette mais c'est une adaptation
malheureusement à une situation
objective qui le justifie il me paraît
j'ai apprécié que des raisons médicales
les raisons d'éloignement les pratiques
artistiques et les convictions
philosophiques je connais des téoz aux
chiens qui veulent que leur enfant ait
montessori enfin il ya comme ça des
margines allemande et des personnes qui
ne se sentent pas à l'aise dans
l'entente de l'enseignement public et je
trouve que ça fait partie de leur
liberté d'avoir d'autres formules et
donc l'autorisation préalable et un est
pour moi un regret mais je crois que
malheureusement elle est nécessaire
étant donné des remontées du terrain que
nous avons les dernières le monde en
remontées du terrain partout vous donner
un exemple c'est maintenant des pères
qui amenant leur petite fille à l'école
maternelle trois ans donc donne comme
condition qu'elles ne soient pas assise
à côté d'un petit garçon et qu'elle ne
joue pas dans la cour de récréation avec
un petit garçon et nous avons le cas
d'un père qui reste derrière là derrière
la grille pour vérifier que pendant la
récréation
l'un sa fille ne joue pas avec des
petits garçons
donc nous avons vraiment des problèmes
qui sont des problèmes qui remettent en
question notre nos valeurs collectives
et les valeurs de la démocratie
autrement dit les deux grands problèmes
que posent un islamisme extrémiste qui
sont le refus de la séparation du
politique et du religieux
c'est à dire que la loi religieuse prime
la loi républicaine ce qu'évidemment
nous ne pouvons pas accepter et
l'égalité du statut des hommes des
hommes et des fins alors après ces
considérations qui s'efforce de de
justifier ma réponse à la question une
je vous donne quelques éléments sur le
rôle du conseil des sages
donc c'est les charges de laïcité au
ministère d'éducation nationale vous
l'avez dit monsieur le président c'est
une décision du
une deux ministres de l'éducation
nationale qui a requis on a choisi les
membres et la précédente sans leur
demander sans demander son avis à
présent donc il a formé cette cette
commission nous l'avons le rôle devient
tellement large que nous avons pu nous
étions 12 à l'origine mais d'abord nous
avons eu deux personnes qui avaient des
problèmes de santé
donc nous avons recruté quatre personnes
de plus parce que nous avons beaucoup de
travail et nous travaillons et nous
travaillons beaucoup
alors pour répondre aux questions
précises que vous posiez nous avons
essayé n'ont pas du tout faire un texte
depuis sur la laïcité vous savez que la
laïcité à la française peut aller dans
une bibliothèque ça occupe des rayons
sans fin et ce groupe n'avait pas de
raisons particulières d'ajouter quoi que
ce soit à la réflexion philosophique
historique sociologique et c'est sur la
laïcité en france ce qu'elle ce qu'il a
voulu cet être aussi utile que possible
en plus ça résolvait les problèmes des
différences de sensibilité qui à
l'intérieur du qui à l'intérieur du
groupe et qui permet tent et que tout ce
que nous nous retrouvions tous autour
d'un certain nombre de solutions à
apporter et dead à apporter au
fonctionnement du ministère s'agissant
de la laïcité et donc nous sommes très
soucieux d'être en liaison pour répondre
à votre question avec les services du
ministère parce que sinon nous sommes
hors sol et avec les référents laïcité
le ministre a nommé dans chaque académie
un référent laïcité avec avec lesquels
qui se réunissent aussi nationalement
assez régulièrement et avec lesquels
nous sommes en relation en permanente et
en est permanente et c'est c'est
nécessaire pour être alors on ne l'est
jamais suffisamment dans le cas de
samuel pâtit
nous avons appris la nouvelle par la
presse donc ce n'était pas remonté
jusqu'à nous mais beaucoup de choses
nous arrive est très souvent nous sommes
saisis par des monts mêlée est inscrit
sur la partie consacrée aux conseils sur
le site du ministère et nous avons des
témoignages de d'enseignants ce qui
frappe actuellement c'est que les
problèmes se déporte vers l'enseignement
primaire
jusqu'à présent c'était lé collège qui
était au coeur des au coeur de la la
contestation
ce qui pouvait aussi s'expliquer par
l'âge des enfants c'est le moment où on
conteste
là on voit qu'il ya une poussée
organisée avec des avocats qui
interviennent qui veulent entrer dans
l'ain qui veulent entrer dans
l'établissement et qui commence très tôt
à partir de la maternelle de donner cet
exemple parce qu'il était le plus
extrême mais il n'est pas seul
c'est animé pas purement anecdotique il
est illustré alors nous avons activement
participé à la rédaction des textes par
lesquels nous essayons de de diffuser ce
qu'est la laïcité d'un point de vue
intellectuel et aussi les conséquences
pratiques dans la gestion des
établissements de ses principes et il y
avait au ministère un projet de vade
mecum de la laïcité qui 2 qui doit et
qui a recueilli l'ensemble des textes et
d'une série d'études de cas pour montrer
comment ces textes s'applique dans tel
ou tel cas alors nous l'avons comment le
dire gentiment nous l'avons beaucoup
nous y avons beaucoup travaillé nous
avions beaucoup travaillé et c'était je
crois utile
il est d'ailleurs il se nourrit des du
terrain et des critiques régulièrement
parce que de nouveaux problèmes
apparaissent que nous n'avions pas
traitée par exemple nous n'avions pas
précisé que quand il y avait un problème
et qu'on rencontrait les parents
d'élèves
il ne fallait pas qu'ils soient
accompagnés par un avocat il venait en
tant que parent d'élève l'entrée des
personnes extérieures qui ne sont pas de
la famille mais qui viennent par les
bons donc il faut prévoir les conditions
dans lesquelles certains parents s'ils
parlent mal français par exemple peuvent
se faire accompagner mais qu'on ne peut
pas accepter ça c'est la suite d'un
certain nombre d'épisodes qui ne sont
pas et donc ce vade-mecum de la laïcité
est mise à jour en fonction des
problèmes qui monte jusqu'à nous on a
rédigé et des arts et la rédaction d'un
vademecum de la lutte contre le racisme
et l'antisémitisme pour essayer de
répondre aux problèmes de certaines
populations sur lesquelles il faut pas
parler d'antisémitisme puisque après
tout ce n'est qu'un racisme sans sans
tenir compte de la spécificité nous
avons nous en avons fait tous avons fait
plusieurs je vous signale on m'a posé la
question pour le sport le sport fait
maintenant partie du périmètre de
monsieur blanc caire et donc nous sommes
en train de reprendre et de rédiger tout
le vade-mecum pour le monde sportif qui
est un monde extraordinairement
compliquée je n'avais pas idée de la
complication à tous points de vue entre
le public et le privé les associations
les fédérations les pouvoirs et qui pour
le dire en termes très modérée ne sait
pas très bien ce que c'est que la
laïcité est donc nous travaillons nous
travaillons à ce texte
on a travaillé aussi pour le service
civique je ne sais pas ce que les
événements du coc vides ont eu comme
conséquences sur l'organisation du du
service civique je pense qu'il est un
peu retardé afin de vous le savez mieux
que moi
mais enfin nous avions
nous avions été consultés nous avons été
faire quelques quelques conférences
quelques conférences de formations et
puis le ministre nous a demandé un
certain nombre de notes par exemple sur
l'enseignement laïc des faits religieux
ou sur tel ou tel problème d'actualité
donc ça c'est la première la première le
premier axe de ce que nous essayons de
faire le deuxième c'est de participer à
la formation des enseignants à la fois
aux recrues parmi au moment du
recrutement et dans la formation
continue
nous avons été j'étais extrêmement
frappé en n'allant pas reparlé à
poitiers qui est maintenant le centre de
formation des enseignants et en
particulier des chefs d'établissement et
des inspecteurs à quel point il y avait
ceux qui je ne parle même pas de ma
génération tourner mon âge mais la
génération de mes enfants allaient de
soi dans l'application de la laïcité
sans qu'on y pense d'une certaine façon
parce que c'était tout à fait
intériorisée et les conférences que j'ai
pu faire qui me paraissait pour tout
dire assez plate enfin l'un était écouté
avec étonnement il avait d'ailleurs
beaucoup d'intérêt et donc il y à un
huard eu un problème de transmission par
rapport aux jeunes professeurs de 30 à
40 ans qui ne savent plus et donc
donc voila nous participons le mieux
possible
nous essayons de participer parce que
c'est ce qui passe le mieux par les
études de cas et chaque fois ceux qui
sont là en tout cas semblent très
intéressés et
découvrir d'une certaine façon les
problèmes et alors le troisième axe
c'est évidemment de soutenir dans la
mesure où nous le pouvons puisque nous
ne sommes pas un organisme de décision
quelconque mais de soutenir tous ceux
qui nous transmet des témoignages ou qui
demandent des conseils
nous essayons de dd les la hiérarchie
assez différents niveaux de ceux qui
essayent de comprendre et de résister et
avec la le capital de travail que nous
avons fait depuis trois ans il ya un
membre du conseil des sages de
l'éducation nationale qui fait partie de
la mission pour l'ensemble de la
fonction publique qui a organisé madame
la ministre de la fonction publique et
du problème de la laïcité donc le
comment dire le lien est institutionnel
pour répondre à une des questions que
vous avez posé parce que nous avons nous
a semblé utile de à partir de ces trois
ans de travail et donc de ce que nous
avions accumulé en expérience en travail
d'en faire participer l'ensemble de la
fonction publique nous savons qu'il ya
de gros problèmes aussi au ministère de
la santé il en a d'autres en ce moment
donc il n'y a plus le temps de s'en
occuper sans doute en ce moment parce
que il est sur la brèche mais le
problème existe toujours et se repent
reportera et donc l'ensemble de
l'ensemble de la fonction publique doit
servir et donc il ya une il ya un lien
institutionnel pour le faire participer
voilà messieurs les présidents
présentation rapide mais merci madame
penser cette présentation rapide mais
déjà très complète je ne doute pas que
nous sommes nombreux à avoir envie de
vous poser des questions on va peut-être
commencer puis
avec ses nombreux à porter mais par
stéphane pieds noirs qui apportera
notamment les les questions sur
l'enseignement et le sport comme vous
l'avez abordé je pense qu'il a des
questions précises à vous poser merci
messieurs les présidents et mesdames les
rapporteurs de me laisser la parole
merci à l'état perd deux de vos propos
et votre exposé qu'on soit vous l'avez
dit que ce texte ne modifie pas la
laïcité dans dans la société française
en revanche peut-être que la laïcité a
évolué tout seul au sein de la société
française vous l'évoquiez avec un
instant avec les différences de profil
des enseignants au fil du temps laïcité
qui paraissait quelque chose de dîners
ou en tout cas de bien de bien assimiler
et de bien enseigner du coup pour une
génération d'enseignants qui l'est
beaucoup moins vous l'avez dit l'islam a
laissé parfois évidemment on va éviter
de généraliser dans nos propos mais a
laissé place à un islam politique un
islamisme en réalité qui qui évidemment
est rampant et nous inquiète à plus d'un
titre dans le corps professoral et on
fait face à des demandes de plus en plus
exubérante c'est à dire des étés niveau
des pratiques vous l'avez dit sur
l'alimentation mais on a aussi affaire à
des demandes des dispenses de pratiques
sportives on pense tous aux certificats
de complaisance pour le ps et plus
particulièrement pour pour le la piscine
pour les cours de natation
on contourne avec dès aujourd'hui une
règle de deux des trois mois de dispense
cumulés dont on peut se demander s'il
est toujours c'est toujours aussi
pertinente
tout ça pour dire que vous avez donc
réaliser ce vade-mecum qui qui s'est
imposée et qui ont la nécessité s'est
imposé au fil du temps est-ce que
est-ce que c'est suffisant est ce qu'on
doit pour autant faire une loi
doit-on faire une loi à partir de
certains exemples que l'on a constatés
ou si tu y es tout à l'heure un parent
d'élève qui observaient si sa petite
fille était bien séparées des garçons
dans la cour d'école
est-ce que c'est cela que l'on doit
cibler dans cette dans cette loi si ces
cas là sont repérés est-ce qu'on peut
les sanctionner ce qu'on a ce qu'on a
d'autres moyens qu'un texte sur
l'instruction en famille par exemple
pour pour y faire face et par ailleurs
sur la sur la laïcité le côté enseignant
fait que vous le savez à un enseignant
sur deux à peu près selon un sondage à
dire toujours des marges d'erreur
un enseignant sur deux s'est auto
censurés sur des pratiques pédagogiques
ça en dit long sur la peur qui a gagné
petit à petit le corps professoral et
certains ont observé une forme de de
contestation pour des motifs religieux à
l'intérieur même à l'intérieur même de
leur salle de cours donc pour leur
liberté pédagogique qui est largement
entamé donc est ce que est ce que le
vade-mecum répond apporte une partie de
la réponse à ces dérives
est ce que la loi qui est en préparation
va permettre d'enfoncer le clou si je
puis dire et d'ancrer dans le marbre d
une répression de ces dérives et si si
je peux me permettre d' une petite
parenthèse sur le sport est dit vous
allez vous attaquer avec des mains comme
sur le sport j'ai vraiment envie de vous
souhaiter bon courage
parce que là aussi c'est un chantier
absolument démentielle quand on sait
l'ampleur des infrastructures qui sont
utilisés public privé qui sont utilisés
pour la pratique du sport
je vous souhaite vraiment beaucoup et je
me serais je serais curieux de voir le
résultat dans de vos travaux dans
quelques quelques mois
merci je rapporte est-ce que du côté des
rapporteurs de la commission des lois
on est je vous propose qu'on essaye de
faire des questions courtes de façon à
ce que tout le monde puisse participer
et poser des questions et les sionistes
a peur ensuite répondre qu'on les avait
très très court je vous en prie enfin
pas trop non plus pas non plus une
censure absolue merci à vian et dames
pour vos propos et est vraiment c'est
important d'entendre parler de laïcité
aujourd'hui voilà parce que dans tous
aux auditions c'est après fin qu'on
parle de ce sujet moi j'ai deux
questions je veux pour moi la laïcité
elle et émancipatrice et les
protectrices
voilà on le dit pas assez on le porte
pas assez mais c'est quand même deux
mots qu'on doit associer laïcité elle
est vraiment émancipatrice et autres
actrices et on pourrait développer je
pourrais développer mais je ne le ferai
pas je vais rassurer les deux présidents
des commissions
moi je voulais vous poser une question
parce que je ne dis pas que j'ai lu tout
ce projet de loi de la première d'un
première lettre de l herbe on parle pas
de la cité dans ce texte on en parle
absolument pas absente et est nommé
julien comme c'est un sujet qui peut
aussi protéger l'institution scolaire
comme la laïcité
pour moi les émancipatrice et
protectrice je trouve un peu regrettable
qu'on n'en parle pas je pense que c'est
un petit peu dommage
et d'ailleurs dans le projet de l'aude
le projet de texte
donnons pas la charte de la laïcité mais
de contrat républicain c'est ça voilà on
n'en parle pas non plus on en parle
absolument pas c'est pas cités il ya
plein de choses qui sont cités mais le
respect de la laïcité n'est pas du tout
posé dans le projet de décret ce contrat
dont moi ça me pose question quand même
parce que on sait que au niveau
l'éducation nationale c'est la clé de la
résolution de l'entrisme à l'école elle
est là la clé c'est d'imposer cette
laïcité protectrice émancipatrice mais
on n'en parle pas dans ce projet de loi
ni dans ce contrat qui est prévu dont
dont je me dis où est la ligne et à quoi
ça sert voilà c'est une petite question
enfin peut-être manqué
y'a pas de problème vous avez juste deux
heures pour répondre merci beaucoup
monsieur le président merci beaucoup
madame de votre présentation moi j'ai
une première question qui s'adresse pour
le coup à la présidente du conseil des
sages et city au niveau d'éducation
nationale nous avons eu un retour
d'associations et notamment
d'enseignante nous disons qu'au niveau
de la formation des enseignants sur la
laïcité elle trouvait ça relativement
indigents c'est à dire qu'en gros on
était sur les grands principes tout le
monde il est beau tout le monde il est
gentil mais assez peu sur les problèmes
techniques et de justement pratique de
façon pratique comment on fait pour ne
pas censurer comment on fait pour
aborder un certain nombre de sujets et
donc pouvoir parler aussi de la laïcité
mais de tous les sujets et ensuite je
m'adresserai plutôt à la sociologue
j'ai lu dans un entretien que vous aviez
eu vous parliez de l'affaiblissement de
la dimension civique et de la
dissolution du cim sentiment national et
patriotique qui laissait place justement
au développement d identification
particulières qu'elles soient
religieuses régionales ou ethnique et il
me semble qu'on est aussi on sent ça
alors effectivement là aujourd'hui on a
un problème avec cet islam radical
mais finalement pas que et j'ai
l'impression que ce mouvement est quand
même assez mondiale puisque on voit bien
les problèmes qui peut y avoir en
catalogne enfin donc ses sentiments
effectivement d'appartenance
indépendamment de cette nation comment
est-ce qu'on peut essayer de
reconstruire quelque chose justement qui
permettent de nouveau de formation et de
d'être supérieur finalement à ce que la
religion pourrait éventuellement de
dictée et ensuite on a encore on sait
par islam politique et islam religieux
mais quand on parle de séparation en
femme de dean égalité homme femme
il me semble qu'elle n'ait pas porté que
par les cinq politique mais aussi
clairement par l'islam religieux donc
comment faire pour lutter contre cette
conception qui de toute façon vient
derrière ensuite pervertir toutes nos
relations sociales
indépendamment même de tous lieux de
culte leurs portes à la présidence je
propose de prendre deux autres question
évoque je le prends deux de questions
peut-être pour saisir nas il y en a pas
je vis la sampdoria de gênes
max brisson max brisson et puis on va
faire un culte et une culture une
commission culture une commission loi si
vous êtes d'accord qu'il est ces prix
sont valables jourda et puis après
madame la présidente vous en a parlé
mais si le président ma question sera
très courte
madame vous avez indiqué que vous vous
avez exprimé un regret concernant la
suppression de l'instruction à domicile
eux portés par l'article 21 de ce projet
de loi et vous l'avez dit deux fois et
vous avez ensuite indiqué
un peu à regret que la situation
actuelle le justifier mais vous avez
donné un exemple qui concernait une cour
de récréation c'est à dire une cour
d'école dont pouvez-vous quantifier ce
que le gouvernement n'a pas pu faire
jusqu'à présent lors des débats à
l'assemblée nationale
pouvez vous nous dire en quoi pour
reprendre l'expression pour lutter
contre l'islamisme
la suppression de destruction à domicile
est une nécessité comme vous l'avait
indiqué le shérif madame jourda si
d'autres personnes veulent poser des
questions ensuite levé la main en ne
devenant comme ça les choses avancent
merci messieurs président j'ai une
question quelque peu de technique on
entend bien qu' il faut clarifier la
question de la laïcité à l'école
notamment et dans le milieu du sport il
existe aujourd'hui des vade mecum et des
guides qui sont édités par
l'observatoire de la laïcité
sauf erreur de ma part le président hu
certains sollicitent et siège au sein du
conseil
comment vont s'articuler vos travaux car
s'il faut de la clarté il ne faut pas
multiplier non plus les publications
semble-t-il officielle sur le sujet
cette première série de questions se
prépare
oui cette année mais alors dire est ce
que une loi sera suffisante
je dirais par définition une loi n'est
pas suffisante elle à 9 heures je n'ai
pas l'espoir que cette loi résolve tous
les problèmes
tous les problèmes que que posent les
atteintes que nous constatons à l'égard
de la laïcité c'est à dire la
contestation des des principes
démocratiques
mais en même temps à la fois il faut
savoir que par définition toute loi est
limité mais en même temps je pense qu'en
posant qu'en donnant des instruments
juridiques à ceux qui veulent lutter à
ceux qui veulent comprendre à ceux qui
veulent résister ça n'est jamais inutile
donc je pense qu'il faut à la fois
savoir apprendre pleine conscience des
limites de la loi mais en même temps ne
pas négliger ce que l'instrument
juridique peut apporter la meilleure
preuve étant que ceux qui la contestent
se fonde sur se fonde sur des arguments
juridiques
il ya des spécialités des avocats
spécialistes de ces problèmes et donc
ils sentent bien que par l'intermédiaire
du droit ils ont une action possible et
par conséquent avec le la comment dire
avec la réticence que que vous exprimiez
le l'introduction de la loi est un est
un instrument parmi d'autres même s'ils
ne sont pas suffisants alors la piscine
et les certificats qu'on peut appeler de
complaisance puisque tout d'un coup
quinze jeunes filles sont allergiques au
chlore enfin nous connaissons le
problème nous avons été nous avons
essayé de traiter le problème
nous sommes en discussion avec l'ordre
des médecins
nous allons faire une note
complémentaire enfin cédant discussions
avec le service juridique du ministère
de l'éducation nationale de voir comment
en respectant le secret médical
certains indices permettrait de faire le
contrôle de ces de ces certificats par
le médecin le médecin scolaire
donc nous sommes nous travaillons là
dessus voilà et nous savons que c'est je
précise que vous avez tout à fait raison
de dire que les principes de la laïcité
sont fondamentalement les mêmes mais en
même temps la laïcité a évolué avec
toute la soirée avec la société
je crois que je l'avais dit et ça je
vous suis tout à fait alors que sur les
sports merci de vos encouragements
c'est ce que nous avons constaté ça
c'est ce que nous avons constaté j'ai
découvert je dois dire que je l'ignorais
tout à fait le monde sportif qui est
vraiment à un bon et
sur lequel il faut essayer de il faut
essayer sans se faire trop d'illusions
ce que nous essayons de faire c'est de
mettre les choses claires
intellectuellement parce qu'il faut
commencer à les penser juste et à aider
ceux qui ceux qui essayent de résister
voilà sans illusion excessive sur notre
pouvoir est le sens de notre action
mais j'aime à penser qui j'aime à penser
qui n'est pas nulle et que pour beaucoup
d'enseignants sentir que la hiérarchie
que les soutiens dans leur combat pour
la laïcité peut avoir une se peut les
aider et quand tout cas si on ne les
soutient pas on est sûr de perdre et
donc il faut tout de même essayer de
leur donner les instruments
intellectuelle et le sentiment qu'ils
sont soutenus par la hiérarchie et qu'il
pourrait sur ces sujets avoir un travail
collectif parce que je crois que ce qui
nous apparaît sur les gars qui remonte
c'est le problème de la solitude de
beaucoup d'enseignants enfin qu'ils se
sentent qu'ils se sentent très seuls
et donc de les encourager au travail
collectif sur ces sujets en leur donnant
des instruments intellectuelle voilà ce
que nous pouvons faire ce que nous
essayons de faire alors oui là en effet
la laïcité et émancipatrice et
protectrice je suis tout à fait d'accord
le mot laïcité n'est pas dans la loi de
1905 je ne sais pas si c'est la raison
pour laquelle on n'en parle pas là mais
je suis de votre avis parce que la
laïcité est une des dimensions du projet
démocratique car sous le terme de
laïcité qui est la forme française de la
séparation du politique et du religieux
on renvoie à ce principe qui est
fondateur de toutes les démocraties
c'est à dire un principe de séparation
du politique et du religieux alors la
laïcité c'est la forme française là ces
caractéristiques qui sont dus à
l'histoire c'est pas la même forme que
celle d'autres démocraties
d'où les difficiles les difficultés de
compréhension de nos problèmes par
d'autres pays mais il n'en reste pas
respecte pas moi ce principe essentiel
de séparation du politique et du
religieux qui fonde les démocraties par
rapport à tous les autres types tous les
autres types de régime alors est ce que
la loi réduit en réduit en parle et on
on peut participer
on peut partager votre votre grève mais
il n'est pas dans notre dans notre
périmètre
oui la formation a été à la laïcité
c'est ce que nous appelons le prêchi
prêcha c'est ça ça tourne au prêchi
prêcha d'où l'importance que nous que
nous avons apportées et d'un et quand
nous allons parler et dans les textes au
cas concret pour sortir parce que c'est
très facile d'avoir ce d'avoir ce
discours grandiose
voilà tout le monde peut la voir la
question c'est qu'il se traduise par des
comportements et donc c'est ce que nous
essayons de faire dans la mesure du
possible nous avons constaté à poitiers
où nous intervenons régulièrement que ce
qui en fin ce qu'il ya de l'écho c'est
moi la conférence inaugurale que je fais
parce qu'il faut mettre le banc que les
ateliers ensuite où on discute sur des
cas concrets
l'application donc je vous suis tout à
fait alors si je savais comment
reconstruire un sentiment civique par
rapport au jeu c'est de l'analyse là
pour lesquelles je n'ai pas de réponse
alors l'inégalité hommes femmes c'est un
problème visiblement très central toutes
les religions ont été fondés sur ce
qu'on a appelé par politesse la
complémentarité mais qui est tout de
même les inégalités des hommes du jeu de
statut sourçage et parler le statut d
homme du statut des hommes et des femmes
visiblement c'est je l'avais observée il
ya il ya quarante ans de saint que les
populations musulmanes qui devait très
proche des français quantic au budo bout
de quelques années il y avait quelque
chose qui résistaient absolument qui
était la répartition des sexes et des
générations et la ont touché quelque
chose de très dur ce que j'avais appelé
le noyau dur culturelles et des enquêtes
par la suite ont constaté que des jeunes
musulmans qui avaient les mêmes goûts
les mêmes pratiques le même comportement
que les autres gardent est sur ces
sujets quelque chose qui étaient
extrêmement extrêmement dur alors les
autres religions ne sont pas à l'abri de
mais elles ont depuis les religions
chrétiennes le judaïsme a été obligé de
construire de faire des mouvements
libéraux pour que les femmes cessent
d'être en haut de la synagogue à ces
éléments
mais il y avait la possibilité créer des
mouvements libéraux et
le grand rabbin korsia suis ce que dit
le consistoire là dessus bon c'est alors
cela dit dans l'islam tel qu'il est con
de pratiquer parce que le talent et le
texte le coran est un texte dont vous
savez la date est donc ce qui est dit
dans le coran il faut leur interpréter
mais il souhaite il faut que les
musulmans acceptent l'idée de
réinterpréter le coran
alors c'est ce que fait l'un des membres
du conseil
c'est à dire ghaleb bencheikh qui est
président de la fondation de l'islam qui
lui ne cesse de dire mais le voile n'a
rien d'islamique surtout ne dites pas le
voile islamique c'est un oxymore
c'est le voile l'islam net ne donne pas
du tout l'ordre de aux femmes de porter
bon et qui est pour une ré
interprétation de l'islam comme données
spirituel c'est à eux de faire le
travail
c'est ne pouvons pas le faire pour eux
alors oui des instructions à domicile
moi je préfère toujours bien que
républicaine ou parce que républicaine
je suis libéral donc je pense qu'il est
toujours mieux de laisser la liberté de
nos parents de décider que il trouve que
l'enseignement public n'est pas ce qu'il
convient leurs enfants pour des raisons
éventuellement matériel de santé de good
de pratiques sportives ou musicales ou
bien de conviction à partir du moment où
ils acceptent le contrôle qui permet
ensuite de voir que par ce qui comme
vous savez il n'ya pas une obligation de
fréquentation de l'école il ya une
obligation d'enseignement et donc si
l'enseignement passe par d'autres voies
sous le contrôle de l'éducation
nationale ça me paraît une décision de
liberté des libertés publiques
le problème est que
[Musique]
lacerte d'une certaine résistance de
l'école publique a pour conséquence
maintenant que les filles ne sont plus
ne sont plus instruites du tout au nom
de la liberté de l'enseignement en
famille il se passe des phénomènes qui
sont aux dépens de ces malheureuses de
ces malheureuses gamine qui n'ont pas
n'ont pas d'instructions et par
conséquent on est je pense qu'il est
justifié de que le régime soit le
produit d'une d'une demande d'une
demande elle-même justifié pour accepter
que les enseignements en famille ne soit
pas simplement un moyen de faire
échapper les filles
au programme 2 et aux valeurs de
l'enseignement public
je regrette qu'on soit dans cette
situation encore une fois mais en même
temps je pense que et en est ce qu'on
voit c'est une réponse à une c'est la
réponse qu'on peut avoir à une situation
qui devient de plus en plus de plus en
plus inquiétante alors l'observatoire de
la laïcité monsieur bianco fait en effet
partie du du conseil du conseil des
sages
nous travaillons ensemble au texte sans
aucun sans aucun problème
nous n'avons pas tout à fait
les mêmes les mêmes conceptions nous
n'avons pas donc je continue mon propos
je vous gardez vos réflexions et je suis
donc nous n'avons nous avons dont des
options qui sont qui ne sont pas les
mêmes mais la collaboration avec je me
flatte en tant que présidente d'avoir
établi une collaboration avec monsieur
bianco qui ne pose aucun problème il ya
eu une seule fois où nous avons transmis
un texte avec lequel il n'était pas
d'accord et en accord avec lui j'ai dit
que nous précise que nous précise riom
en le transmettant aux ministres parce
que je n'ai jamais fait voter le conseil
travaille dans dans l'unanimité je n'ai
jamais fait voter et il ya eu un cas où
j'ai dit que monsieur b en cause s'il en
était d'accord que je transmettrai qu'il
n'était pas d'accord avec cette et nous
sommes tombés d'accord sur ce désaccord
mais ça a été une seule fois et tout le
reste du temps ça se passe très bien
monsieur le président ce que vous me
permettez de préciser ma question en
réalité ce qui m'inquiète et votre
réponse m'inquiète encore plus et que il
se peut qu'il y cohabitent deux
type de vade mecum et deux guides qui
serait l'un comme l'autre en quelque
sorte subventionné même si ça n'est pas
une question d'argent par le ministère
et comment fait-on dans l'éducation
nationale ou dans le sport
une fois qu'on a ces deux vade mecum
puisque ça existe déjà l'observent de
laïcité à nombre de vade mecum guide
assez impressionnant nous allons le
revoilà comment fait-on pour choisir
celui qui va être appliqué alors que
j'ai le sentiment vous n'aurez pas tout
à fait la même position sur la question
c'est pas un sentiment c'est un fait
donc je vous l'accordé volontiers
écouter le l'observatoire de la laïcité
remis en question à partir du 1er avril
et donc nous verrons à ce moment là ce
qui se passe nora choix politiques
il est clair que la position que nous
avons et qui essaie et qui est avec des
nuances personnel mais qui en gros et
celle du ministre de l'éducation
nationale n'est pas la même que celle de
l'observatoire de la laïcité
et donc c'est je pense que ça se fera au
niveau du président de la république que
le choix de la manière dont c'est dans
ces deux organismes ne vont pas être en
contradiction mais il ya un vrai
problème
merci on va prendre une autre série de
questions vous propose de poser
l'ensemble des questions que ça m'a
acheté pour pouvoir y répondre en
essayant d'être assez bref bien entendu
pierre auzias et puis après madame
harribey qui doit être derrière son
écran après jacques grosperrin thomas
d'hossus qui est également derrière son
écran et jean reno et de neige merci
monsieur le président merci beaucoup
madame là il vous m'entendez bien la
voilà donc je suis fier ouzoulias
sénateur des hauts-de-seine
voilà merci pour votre propos moi
j'aimerais questionner votre pratique de
sociologues dans un premier temps sur
des changements profonds liés à la
conception philosophique général de la
laïcité tel qu'on peut le percevoir
aujourd'hui qui porte sur une remise en
question de la dimension humaniste
universel de la laïcité dans le
prolongement de la philosophie des
lumières et de ce que la révolution
française à bâtir à partir de la ushl à
hong kong
aujourd'hui dans le débat actuel et je
me place résolument en dehors de toute
polémique stérile momentanée et est
futile
on a tendance à considérer que cette
révision de des formes universels de
pensée de citoyenneté nous viennent des
états unis est ce que vous ne pensez pas
que les prémisses si on fait une
archéologie de ces notions ne serait pas
à trouver dans la sociologie française
de la fin des années soixante dix et
notamment de la pensée de quelqu'un
comme michel foucault je pourrais
prendre quelques quelques citations où
on sent que
il ya une remise en question du
caractère universel de de la citoyenneté
vous n'êtes pas obligé de me répondre
comme ça je joue mais ça laisse ensuite
plusieurs de nos collègues et madame là
la rapporteure demandé une définition de
la laïcité
vous en avez produite une qui est
admirable et que vous me permettrai de
deux cités dans votre votre article la
république face au communautarisme
études 2004 page 177 jeu suit le rôle
premier de l'état reste d'organiser
l'unité de l'espace politique commun qui
permet d'intégrer par l'abstraction et
l'égalité formelle de la citoyenneté
tous les individus quels que soient
leurs origines sociales religieuses
régionales ou nationales
j'ai absolument rien à enlever a ajouté
et j'aimerais même proposée par un
amendement que sa figure en préambule de
la loi dont nous discutions voilà ce que
je trouve que cette définition est
parfaitement juste et correspond en ce
qui me concerne moi à mon idéal laïc et
républicain
je vais vite je vous rassure monsieur le
président à la fin de cet article
il y à un paragraphe ici là que
j'aimerais vous poser une question vous
dites une société démocratique implique
que par delà ces fidélité particulière
légitimes chacun puisse aussi rencontrer
et reconnaître l'autre avec un a
majuscule au nom des valeurs
universelles de la citoyenneté le
communautarisme devrait rester laisser
la liberté et à l'initiative des
individus encouragés par une application
souple de la citoyenneté républicaine
cela est conforme à la fois la tradition
de la tigresse est française et à la
légitimité des sociétés modernes qui
repose sur l'universalité des droits du
citoyen et de la protection de l'état
providence alors je vous rassure je vous
questionne pas sur la protection de
l'état providence mais en revanche
j'aimerais que vous nous expliquer un
peu ce que vous voulez ce que vous
entendez par une application souple de
la citoyenneté républicaine
merci madame la présidente laurence
harribey
entendez ici alimentant des cd volés
très bien m merci messieurs les prêts et
les présidents m'ont ma question de va
être beaucoup plus courte mais même si
quelque part elle revient un petit peu à
la même thématique
vous avez dit au tout début de votre
propos en répondant au questionnaire qui
vous était proposé que vous considériez
que le texte ne mettait pas en cause la
conception de la laïcité et ne portait
pas atteinte à la liberté du culte alors
c'est difficile de remettre en cause la
conception de la laïcité puisque on n'en
parle pas dans le texte
par contre sur porter atteinte à la
liberté du culte moi j'aimerais mettre
l'accent sur deux petites choses qui me
pose problème dans ce texte
dans l'article 26 on prévoit la
nécessité d'organes délibérant excepté
pour ce qui concerne le ministre du
culte quand il ne dépend pas d'eux de
l'association en question mais quelque
part ça met le doigt dans l'engrenage de
définir dans la loi ce qu'est l'exercice
du culte et là à mon avis on est dans
une contradiction avec ce qu'est la
laïcité et en plus je pense que ça ça ne
colle ça ne répond pas à la question qui
nous est posée du point de vue de nos
problèmes de société puisqu'on peut
facilement détourné sa part le la
pratique d'intervenants occasionnels ou
de ne pas avoir de procédure de
nomination de ministère du culte et puis
liés à cette question là dans l'article
la combinaison de l'article 6 du texte
avec l'article 33 sur le régime des
subventions comment peut-on vraiment
différencier ce qui est de l'associatif
de ce qui est du cultuel est ce qu'il
valait mieux pas à ce moment-là dire
carrément que on avait un régime loi de
1905 et un régime loi 1901 pour ce qui
est pratique
associative ouverte sur le sur la
société il ya un problème pour nombre de
d'associations ou la frontière entre
l'associatif et le cultuel est très
difficile et donc ça obligera des double
comptabilité et à d adhérer ce crime de
nature différente
merci jacques grosperrin
merci messieurs les présidents madame la
présidente moi j'ai bien entendu vos
propos liminaire plus cautionner et
néanmoins sincère parce que je pense que
dès qu'on parle de laïcité c'est
toujours compliqué et même si s'est
imposée à partir de 1905 comme une
démarche de liberté certains pendant
très longtemps
vous les trouvez une laïcité ouverte ou
fermée ou aux soupes ou conservatrices
ou progressif
en réalité il ya qu une des cités tout
simplement et qui est accepté ou qui n'a
pas accepté et c'est ça aussi la
problématique qu'on rencontre dans les
établissements scolaires parce que c'est
elle dans les établissements scolaires
qui fait partager les valeurs de la
république la laïcité dont à mon avis
c'est important vous avez répondu à la
question sur l'instruction en famille
donc je ne viendrai pas mais je pense
que c'est important ça serait
fondamental de laisser aussi cette
liberté aux parents le faire deuxième
question deuxième fois c'est sûr le nom
qui a changé vous avez dit
forte heureusement le nom a changé
est-ce que vous parliez du mot
séparatisme séparatisme n'est pas un
gros mot
ferdinand buisson lorsqu'il l'a utilisé
c'était une manière pour lui d'exprimer
le religieux d'exprimer beaucoup de
choses par rapport à ça et je pense que
l'origine l'originalité de l'école
publique c'est qu'elle n'appartient pas
à personne mais à tous et je crois que
il a essayé de fond dit justement cette
conception là sur le séparatisme
confessionnelle pour dire que c'était la
fraternité nationale qu'il recherchait
dans un article la foi laïque y parle
justement qu'il voulait lutter non pas
contre la foi et vous l'avez fort bien
dit tout à l'heure mais contre la haine
donc moi j'ai l'impression que l'on
refait du aubin où la vie dit tout à
l'heure vous l'avais regretté on refait
duo ben 2002 parce qu'on n'ose pas
redire le mot séparatisme et on n'ose
pas même aller plus loin parce qu'à ce
jour il ya séparatisme
islamique et je crois que c'est une
question à mon avis qui est important et
tout tourne eu un petit peu autour de
cela parce que si on n'est pas capable
de citer les mots ou de dire les mots
qui sont sur un problème on en train de
faire l'amalgamé puis on est on est en
train de déplacer toutes les religions
alors que les religions ne sont pas dans
à l'école en tout cas c'est pas le
problème de la région allant à l'école
et vous l'avait bien dit tout à l'heure
est on en train de se tromper de chemin
merci thomas dessus qui oui bonjour
merci vous montrez bien après donc là on
annonce est pas la première audition
qu'on a on entend souvent ça tombe
d'exemple à qui veut nous montrer qu'ils
veulent nous montrer une dérive qu'il
faut combattre sûr que ce texte est fait
pour ça mais je voulais revenir sur une
question que max brisson a posé et que
vous n'avez pas forcément adressé ce
taxi tapas et l'environnement en cause
un certain nombre d qui vise notamment
sur l'instruction en famille et vous
avez vous à verdi là dans votre réponse
ensuite certains les filles ne sont plus
instruite
je trouve ça un peu compliqué et conseil
d'état le trouvais aussi quand on ne
donne pas de chiffres ou de ou de
tendances vraiment clair de pouvoir
taper aussi fort sur un équilibre qu'on
avait trouvé dans l'instruction libre
sans avoir de données quantifiées est ce
que le conseil des sages laïcité produit
un certain nombre de données un peu plus
quantitative pour qui nous permettrait
un peu de savoir si ce texte est une
réponse proportionnée une vraie tendance
ou si on tape très large et en risque de
bouleverser un certain nombre d'
équilibre dans notre éducation
merci jean raymond gonnet merci
président ce qu'il ya d'intéressant dans
dans tout cela et merci madame de
l'éclairage que vous portez aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on parle beaucoup plus du fond
c'est à dire de la laïcité
plutôt que du texte qui nous est
présenté et pour ma part je goûte peu la
législation d'émotion et ce texte
est une législation d'émotion alors en
revanche en terme de laïcité la loi de
quand on est arrivé à ce compromis
je note d'ailleurs au passage en ayant
regardé un petit peu les choses que le
sénat ne s'étaient pas prononcés à
l'époque et pourtant quand il ya des
débats très très profond
le sénat est souvent un équilibre entre
en tout cas arriva à à confectionner cet
équilibre si on parle de laïcité moi y'a
quelqu'un alors je vais pas dire que
c'est ma bible mais il ya un ouvrage
remarquable qui s'appelle le
dictionnaire amoureux de la laïcité
d'henri penaruiz le philosophe qui ne
fait pas partie
étrangement de ce conseil des sages de
la laïcité dont il serait intéressant de
savoir madame comment justement la
composition a été fait puisque par les
temps qui courent les comités les
conseils se multiplient sans qu'on sache
exactement comment sont désignés les
membres et il dit quelque chose et c'est
ma question et dit quelque chose de tout
à fait pertinents les religions ne sont
pas dangereuses c est le langage que les
croyants nous sommes tous d'accord là
dessus
elles le deviennent si elles prétendent
à nouveau dicter la loi commune
ne pensez vous pas que le texte qui nous
arrive n'est pas justement un
retournement de tout cela est en fait
une dernière question valable belrhiti
oui merci monsieur le président c'est
simple une petite question vous avez dit
tout à l'heure que votre deuxième axe le
deuxième acte de vos actions c'était la
formation des enseignants et je voulais
savoir si si les directions des
établissements étaient également formés
parce que vous avez du talent heures
effectivement que les professeurs se
sentent bien souvent très seul face à
ces problématiques est en effet bien
souvent ils ne sont pas soutenues par
par les directeurs d'établissement alors
est-ce qu'on est ce qu'il ya aussi
quelque chose qui est fait dans ce sens
là merci
voilà mesdames ses rythmes aussi on
danse on m'a dit oui c'était très
différentes
alors je vous remercie beaucoup pour
votre pour votre intervention
[Musique]
il ya beaucoup de choses et dans les
deux citations
si je me permets je me suis rendu compte
dans la deuxième citation que j'avais
mal utilisé le terme de communautarisme
et je voulais dire communautaire en
l'occasion donc je vais me rater ce
serait d'aller me corrigez moi même en
vous en vous écoutant mais je vous
remercie beaucoup de ce que vous avez
dit je pense fondamentalement je pense
comme vous que la laïcité est un
héritage des lumières que c'était disons
la tradition de gauche républicaine et
que actuellement la gauche se divisent
entre ceux qui maintiennent ou qu'ils
prolongent tout temps là réinterprétant
cette tradition et ce qui fonde
identitarisme et que c'est une danse est
une des expressions de la crise de la
pensée de gauche alors le rôle de ce que
les américains ont appelé la french
theory c'est à dire la la déconstruction
qui du coup nous revient des états unis
alors qu'ils l'ont emprunté à la france
enfin cette terre et qui en tout cas
remet en question tout l'héritage des
lumières est fondamentalement je crois
que d'un point de vue politique c'est
l'héritage des lumières qui est à la
fois juste et utile et que la
déconstruction pour nous dire que toutes
les constructions sociales et que de
toute façon
bon bah oui toutes les constructions
sociales et alors est ce qu'il faut
c'est que la construction sociale soit à
peu près convenable et c'est ce que
donne c'est ce que donnent les lumières
donc je suis alors ce que je voulais des
eaux par application souple
c'est ce que je sais tu es l'exemple que
je vous avais donné on peut changer
du jeudi au samedi parce que il ya 90 %
d'enfants juifs et donc c'est mieux
ou bien on peut on a est d'ailleurs la
république le fait là une liste des
fêtes qui sont susceptibles d'accord
d'être accordée si le service n'est pas
remis en question c'est une application
souple
au lieu de dire je ne veux pas savoir
nos fêtes sont des fêtes hérité du
christianisme avec leur contrepartie
républicaine on a on à noël qui est
héritée du et le premier de l'an qué bon
mais en gros c'est la tradition
chrétienne et donc les religions qui ont
des fêtes différentes
les chinois en chat ou je ne sais quoi
bon ils manifestent dans les rues voilà
il faut pas trouver là que la laïcité
est mise en question
mais c'est ça que je voulais dire par
application souple c'est à dire qu'on
garde le principe fondamental de la
séparation du politique et du religieux
et puis on sait bien qu'en même temps il
ya une collaboration entre l'état
religieusement neutre et les groupes les
groupes religieux les églises il faut
tenir compte dans la mesure où on peut
si ça ne remet pas en question les
principes communs voilà c'était ça mon
idée d application souple parce que
régulièrement je fais une conférence sur
la laïcité à quelqu'un pour me dire la
france n'est pas laïque parce qu'il ya
la moselle et l'alsace soyez bon je
trouve que c'est il faut respecter
l'histoire qui font que la moselle et
l'alsace bon c'est ça ce que je signifie
par par application souple des principes
de la laïcité alors sur les questions je
ne je n'ai pas de réponse sur le
problème de l'article 26 noeuds rapport
de l'article 6 et 33 je m'en excuse
auprès non je crois que c'était un homme
qui par les autres
oui chers valbon jaune jaune
je ne peux pas répondre parce que je ne
suis pas assez compétente
je n'ai pas examiner le texte d' assez
près pour pouvoir pour pouvoir donner
une réponse qui soit fondée en revanche
sur l'idée qu'il ya eu une laïcité soit
ouverte soit fermées soit soit généreux
soit soir aide fédérale me paraît
absurde la laïcité c'est une c les
données que nous avons explicité
ensemble qui a été qui a été cité et
introduire un adjectif me paraît
contraire à ce qui est la laïcité en
elle même donc je vous suis absolument
reste s'agissant de les modalités
d'application sur le sur l'enseignement
en famille beaucoup sera fait dans les
modalités d'application c'est à dire que
il y aura une autorisation préalable et
contrôle il faut le faire
de façon intelligente quoi c'est
simplement ce que je voulais dire allons
le séparatisme est ce que le changement
de titre sont apparus ne s'est pas le
problème qu'on parlait de séparatistes
c'est le problème que c'était négatif
c'était contre le séparatisme au lieu de
dire pour la liberté
oui et je trouvais que cette loi est il
était mieux de l'a22 pour le
renforcement des principes républicains
disons donc de passer voiliers de la
lutte contre le séparatisme à
l'affirmation dépôts 7 ce qui revient au
même
et donc c'était pas une n'est pas une
réticence à l'égard du terme de
séparatistes c'était une réticence à
l'égard d'un intitulé qui se définissait
négativement ses salles communes
charisme c'est le moment où la loi de la
communauté priment prime la loi
républicaine avant ce sont des liens
communautaires qui sont parfaitement
légitimes
c'est tout et c'est pour ça que j'aurais
pas dû utiliser communautarisme dans la
cité par la citation que vous avez
rappelé parce que ça voulait dire là les
liens communautaires et autant les liens
communautaires qui rapproche ceux qui
partagent une même origine historique
les mêmes convictions politiques
les mêmes croyances religieuses et
naturel évidente est souhaitable ou
d'autant qu'ils s'inscrivent à
l'intérieur de la loi commune et
séparatisme commence quand tu es la loi
commune qui quand cette loi particulière
en temps primer la loi pardon non non
non mais il ne concerne qu'une part à
condition de bien précis du qui ne
concerne qu'une partie du slam c'est
l'islam qui déclare que la loi
religieuse est supérieure à la loi de la
république
alors ça c'est du séparatisme alors si
on parle de séparatistes musulmans c'est
ça l'inconvénient c'est qu'on a l'air de
oui oui voilà mais à partir du moment où
il ya primauté d'une loi particulier à
kessel d'une religion par rapport à la
loi comme on sort de ce que nous pouvons
et on peut l'appeler le séparatisme
séparation d'avec le principe comme
alors les données quantitatives oui nous
savons qu'il ya des dérives il est le
quantitatif droit social pour une
sociologue j'ai à la fois beaucoup de
respect pour les chiffres et beaucoup de
réticences à l'égard de ces chiffres
comment sont faits ces chiffres d'
atteinte à la laïcité
il suppose que le professeur accepte de
les signaler que il le signale à son
chef d'établissement qui acceptent de
les signaler qui ensuite les transmet à
l'inspecteur qui ensuite accepte de les
signaler au rectorat qui lui les
transmet au ministère d'éducation nation
c'est à dire que c'est des chiffres qui
mesure on ne sait pas quoi
parce que quand les professeurs sont
découragés in
une signal plus parce qu'il dit ça sert
à rien de toute façon
et puis ça va me faire des ennuis c'est
donc les chiffres que nous avons sur les
atteintes à la laïcité sont des chiffres
qu'il faut prendre avec énormément de
précautions et l'observatoire de la
laïcité régulièrement dit vous voyez il
n'y a pas beaucoup d' atteinte on a huit
ou neuf cents atteinte
ça n'a vraiment sur un sujet comme ça
les chiffres sont alors cela dit ça ne
répond pas à la question est-ce que
c'est marginal
est ce que c'est un phénomène qui se
soit assez large pour justifier les
interventions et là aussi la réponse est
très difficile parce que nous savons que
ils sont certainement minoritaires par
rapport à la population concernée
ça c'est ce qu'on sait mais les
minorités actives on a toujours su que
les minorités actives avec quelquefois
un pouvoir politique qui n'était pas au
port sionnel alors à leur répartition
statistiques ickler n'a jamais eu une
majorité à l'élection
je veux dire les minorités ont un sens
politique qui peut être plus important
que celui que décrit une majorité d'où
je n'ai pas je n'ai pas de réponse sinon
que le quantitatif n'a que peu de sens
et qu' il n'est pas vraiment le problème
est que un certain nombre d'épisodes
dans certains quartiers peuvent avoir un
sens politique qui dépasse de beaucoup
leur présentation dans l'entente que la
population musulmane majoritaire accepte
les lois républicaines
c'est un fait ça nan ça n'enlève pas le
problème politique que pose une minorité
organisée
intellectuel soutenu par l'extérieur
c'est donc donc c'est dire qu'on prend
des décisions sans être tout à fait sûr
de la manière dont il faut les prendre
alors pourquoi est ce que monsieur
penaruiz n'est pas dans le dans le
conseil je n'en sais rien le conseil a
été formé par monsieur par monsieur
blanc caire sans me demander mon avis il
donc j'ai fait une ou deux suggestions
qu'il a trouvée excellente et dont il
n'a pas tenu compte
[Musique]